Profit experience rumbling sounds in my stomach alone with cramps and pain in my sides.
I also pass gas frequently and sometimes it is an unpleasant order. What steps can I take to
address this issue? So all of these point to mal digestion. So when we have mal digestion,
we're not digesting food properly. So it can be because
from the other question, maybe I have antibodies to food and maybe I'm eating something
that I have antibodies to. Maybe I'm eating gluten that I have antibodies to. So it's causing
this inflammatory response in my gut, so I'm getting mal digestion. So whenever we're getting
a lot of pain, weird feelings in the gut, a lot of gas, it is because of mal digestion.
Meaning the food isn't getting properly digested and it's fermenting.
So number one, it can be food sensitivities. So the only for sure way to know that is to do
a food sensitivity panel. And the only one that I ever recommend is the Syrex 10 or right 10.
But short of that, you could certainly do a food elimination, like oh, it's trying to figure out
is it worse with certain foods? And you can help figure that out.
The second cause of this, these can be combined to understand. The second cause of this is
mal digestion just because of hypochloridria, decreased hydrochloric acid in my stomach, and it
decreased possibly going along with it, of pancreatic enzymes. So I'm not getting good enzymatic
breakdown of my food in the stomach and in mainly in the first part of the small intestine.
And I'm not getting good breakdown of my food in the stomach through HCl secretion. So remember
hypochloridria or decreased stomach acid is the number one disease process if we want to call it
that in the other planet. You know, there's hands down, not even anything close to it. It is
very, very common. Again, the reason is we damage our stomach cells. Just like I said, we damaged our
gut cells and it put leaky gut permeability. We could damage our stomach cells. And the
primal cells are the stomach that secrete HCl are not doing their job and they're not secrete
HCl well. So we get food not not to properly digest it in the stomach and go into the small intestine
fermenting causing gas causing issues. So the first step that I would take of this was me. I would
increase my HCl and digestive enzymes. And we have a product that we've privately labeled that's called
clear digest. So clear digest I would just be taking more of these with each meal. You know,
sometimes people have to get up to taking five, six, seven, eight, nine with each meal. That's
typically not on a regular basis, but you need to get proper digested and get things will be
doing coffee and it's going to really help this too because it's going to help calm things down
and make sure you're you're eliminating as well. Go also look at you guys have full access to the
detoxification course. The seven phases of detoxification look at that too. That's going to give you some
clues and things too. But those are the main things that I would think about for that male digestion.